depuis très très longtemps
si tu peux me permettre de le dire un
militant de l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse et je dois dire que parmi mes
préoccupations il y a les conditions
d'accès les femmes
à ce qu'on appelle une liberté mais ce
qui parfois est
une contrainte aussi et avoir vu 135
fermés en disant ça c'est une vraie
préoccupation avoir vu l'esprit de la
loi veille notamment sur l'entretien
préalable pour ces jeunes femmes puis
j'allais dire la suite
j'allais dire de la technique
chirurgicale qui correspond à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
quand elle n'est pas dans une forme
médicale est-ce qu'on respecte la loi
veille mon premier sujet c'est de
respecter la loi veille si mauvais
disait qu'elle n'était pas favorable à
ce que les sujets sociétaux soient
inscrits comme une forme de catalogue
dans la Constitution c'est ma position
aujourd'hui je n'y suis pas favorable
mais il y a eu un débat au Sénat je suis
président d'une assemblée et qui
respecte aussi les votes qui ont eu lieu
au Sénat sur une proposition
de l'ancien président de la commission
des lois Philippe Bas membre des
républicains il y a eu une proposition
sur la liberté une formulation qui a
repris Emmanuel Macron mais oui j'ai
bien noté et pas du tout la formule que
madame panot avait utilisé on est
aux antipodes en fait le Sénat quelque
part et dans sa vocation d'être attentif
au respect des libertés individuelles et
collectives mais personnellement je
continue à penser et que
la Constitution n'est pas le lieu de
l'inscription de liste des sujets
sociétaux parce que nous aurons d'autres
sujets qui vont venir la fin de vie
de constitution pardon là il s'agit de
mettre l'IVG avec d'autres sujets sur
les régions possiblement la
décentralisation les modes de scrutin
comme d'habitude au Sénat liberté de
vote vote en conscience en suivant merci
serait vigilant merci
[Musique]